بعد ساعه من الان تنطلق مباراه منتخب
الولايات المتحده مع المنتخب الايراني
معركه رياضيه تنقلها السياسه وتثقلها
السياسه ولا مهرب من ذلك قبل المباراه نشر
الاتحاد الامريكي لكره القدم صوره العلم
الايرانيه الاساسيه قبل الثوره الخميليه
اي العلم دون شعار النظام الاتحاد
الامريكي قال لشبكه سي ان ان تغيير العلم
الرسمي سيكون لمده 24 ساعه فقط لاظهار
الدعم للنساء في ايران عدد من مشجعي
المنتخب الايراني حاول دخول المدرجات
حاملين اعلام بلادهم القديمه قبل عهد
خميني في رساله الاحتجاجيه وداعمه
للمتظاهرين لكن الامن رفض دخولها
باعتبارها لافتات سياسيه حسب ما نقلت
رويترز وسائل اعلام رسميه ايرانيه طلبت
بطرد الولايات المتحده من البطوله وايقاف
منتخبها 10 مباريات بسبب نشر صوره مشوهه
للعلم بحسب وصفها طبعا مشاهدينا اي مباراه
بين فريقي البلدين دائما ما حملت جانبا
سياسييا الزميل ليث البزاري امام ستاد
الثمامه ينقل لنا التفاصيل في المتابعه
تنطلق من خلفي بعد اقل من ساعه من الان في
ستاد الثمامه بالعاصمه القطريه الدوحه
مباراه حاميه الوطيس بين منتخبي ايران
وامريكا في الجوله الثالثه الختاميه
لمجموعات بطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم قطر
2022 نظرا للوضع الجيو سياسي بين البلدين
قرارات السلطات القطريه بالتعاون مع
الفيفا بتكثيف اعداد قوات الامن والحمايه
المدنيه في محيط وداخل هذا الملعب يبدو ان
عدد المشجعين الايرانيين اكثر بكثير من
المشجعين الامريكان نظرا لقرب دوله قطر من
ايران ووجود عدد لا باس به من الايرانيين
في المنطقه ما سهل عليها بالقدوم الى هنا
اما المشجعين الامريكيون فقد حضر الكثير
منهم من الولايات المتحده لتشجيع فرقهم
هنا في بطوله العالم في قطر وكذلك السياحه
في الدول العربيه المجاوره من امام استاذ
الثمامه
دوله قطر
[موسيقى]